there's a cool clip of you talking about
Kobe cussing you out over voicemail yes
you said you and I didn't talk for eight
months yes what's the craziest story you
have of a player being upset with you
for something you said and like some
crazy [__] happened that you're
comfortable saying no I would tell you
I've told this story many times and I
actually hate telling it now because I
feel bad because I I just reflect on it
and know how wrong I was but you know we
were in Denver
when Randy Larry brought this 2003
something like that Larry Brown leaves
for Detroit 2003 2004 season Randy Ayers
takes over Randy Ayers takes over
coaching 76s he ultimately gets fired
Glenn Big Dog Robinson
um I thought he could handle things
better whatever whatever I go on TV I
say what I have to say blah blase and
then next thing you know they got a game
in Denver after all-star weekend I walk
in the locker room and big dog gets in
my face you know [__] I saw what
the hell you said you know you ain't
[__] you ain't this you ain't dad blah
blah blah he's talking you know smack to
me in the whole bit I like can I speak
you're like what you know he said you're
no good sorry ass MF for blah blah blah
and I said
my turn
I said I appreciate your honesty because
I feel the exact same way about your
sorry ass you [__] [__] you
think blah blah blah let me get into it
you know what I'm saying and he was like
he said he said man you don't know who I
he said you don't know who I am I'm from
Gary Indiana I said [__] so
it's Michael Jackson
so after all of that after all of that
happened yeah nobody could clean
MJ really good so so after all of that
happened after all of that happened you
know we we never spoke to each other
again the whole bit and then years later
I just felt really bad because I saw him
talking about it and I was like and then
Randy heirs and others got on me because
they were like Let It Go Let It Go Let
It Go and I was like they right and then
I saw a son and his son was in the
league and he was such a nice kid and
everything I didn't want his son looking
at me talking on TV every day thinking
that one day if I spoke about him it was
going to be because law and then I
realized you know how you just look at
somebody and it's like an epiphany hit
you this is all my fault that brother
was a basketball player whatever he felt
about Randy is he felt about Randy is
whatever he felt about his teammates he
felt about his teammates he has that
right he was in that locker room he was
a star player formerly after doing then
in the NBA I wasn't you know he was that
dude and the fact of the matter is Glenn
Big Dog Robinson could ball and the
people that you spoke to most of them
felt he was a really cool brother and
they didn't feel the way that I felt
about him at the time so I was like this
must have been something good about him
the fact of the matter is and I don't
want his son feeling this way so I
walked up to someone I saw his son and I
was like I was totally wrong your father
was right I said I could have handled
things better as I'm the one sitting in
this chair it was my obligation to be
the professional and the grown-up and I
didn't live up to my obligation I want
you to know that if I see your father
I'm going to apologize to him and I want
you to know you never have to worry
about anything that happened with me and
your dad being a reason why I would
judge how you play or anything like that
I'm gonna call it like I see it that's
all you have to worry about with me and
I just felt that that was the right
thing to do and I still feel that way to
this very day because it's on me I'm the
one that's sitting in that chair and I
should have handled it better